ah ouais ça on n'oublie jamais le jour
où l'on dit adieu à sa mère surtout
quand on a 19 ans et qu'il est retrouvée
morte ensanglanté ou bas d'un escalier
je ne mets entre matériaux china
car bien des femmes autochtones
assassinées ou disparues ou bien le mec
d'un ordre la mère de stéphanie étaient
très vulnérables et donc une cible
parfaite mais si stéphanie dit connaître
l'identité de l'assassin de sa mère la
police dément tonnes n'a jamais porté
d'accusation
i was the night watch my way
oh
encore aujourd'hui stéphanie se demande
si les conclusions d'une enquête aurait
été différent si sa mère n'avait pas été
autochtone elle croit comme le souligne
le rapport qu'il faut donner aux
autochtones plus de pouvoir une
meilleure représentation dans la police
notamment des jeunes esprits pour jo
surtout qu'il faut donner à ces femmes
tous les outils pour qu'elles soient
moins ciblé widnes in many many many ce
week end vous sentez aussi un peu
d'acteurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
stéphanie c'est peut-être quand les
filles et les femmes autochtones
retrouveront plus de dignité et d steam
que cesseront d'être des proies faciles
[Musique]